mein Name ist Johanna Costa, ich bin 25 Jahre
alt und ich unterstütze Bernie Sanders. mein Name
ist Maria Avila. Ich bin 65 und ich unterstütze
Bernie Sanders. Hallo, mein Name ist
Mira Rodriguez  ]
Er ist einer der wenigen Kandidaten, die
wirklich darauf achten, was die jüngere
Generation will, besonders wenn es
um die Gesundheitsversorgung und die Möglichkeit
geht, aufs College zu gehen, und ich möchte heute nicht hineingehen,
wie die meisten Amerikaner, also unterstütze ich
seine Idee von einem College für alle
[Musik]
Ich glaube, jeder sollte eine
Gesundheitsversorgung haben. Ich habe eine ausgezeichnete Gesundheitsversorgung, wie
ich letztes Jahr eine Operation hatte, und es war
sehr stressig, als müsste ich mir eine
Auszeit von der Arbeit nehmen, ich musste nur einen
Haufen umziehen  Zeit für Genesung und
alles, und ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen, dass Sie sich darüber hinaus um
Geld sorgen müssen, dass Sie für die Gesundheitsversorgung bezahlen
müssen, worum ich mir keine Sorgen machen musste,
also glaube ich, dass Medicare für alle so ist
Land sollte ja sein, er ist armes
Gehäuse, also ist das ein  Wichtig,
denn ich trage Regenschirme. Ich gehe
jedes Mal, wenn ich meine Rente bekomme. Meine Sozialversicherung
walk mein
Name ist Daniel Robinson und ich bin
ein Hausangestellter und ich unterstütze
Bernie Sanders Goldberg
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Ich denke, unser politisches
Establishment trifft gerne
Entscheidungen für uns, aber wenn Sie sich die
Umfragen ansehen  wie 70 % der Leute glauben, 70 %
der Demokraten glauben, dass er gewinnen kann
[Applaus]
[Musik]
als Kind eines Einwanderers weiß er,
wie es ist, Eltern zu haben, die aus
einem anderen Land kamen, um für ihre
Kinder zu kämpfen, damit sie ihnen ein besseres Leben ermöglichen  Ich
denke, dass er weiß, weil er weiß,
wie es ist, in dieser Situation aufzuwachsen,
viele Latinos und Hispanics verstehen,
weil wir es selbst durchlebt haben, dass es
ihm um die Menschen geht, es gibt eine Sache
, die ihm um die Menschen geht und besonders um das
geringe Einkommen  Leute aus der unteren Mittelschicht,
die wirklich darum kämpfen, dass
du Amerika wieder großartig kennenlernst, aber er nicht so,
wie Trump es sein möchte, sondern so, dass
wir alle vereint sein könnten, kein Name, ich mag
Bernie, er ist ein guter Kerl